all right so this is dad's dungeon which
an submit that title cast scared me I'm
like what the hell is but it's one where
uh Finn and Jake's dad makes a dug din
to toughen up
Finn which of course you're like with it
fits pretty tough by me he's like the
toughest toughest person that you know
honestly uh but the father is an analyst
yes old binds to calles at great line
but he seizes he sees him as a baby
literally holding them as a baby's
things got tough enough but out realize
he's a baby so obviously it doesn't make
much sense oh you just assume she'll
still be like that and it leaves these
video messages and so they go through
the dungeon and Finn's feeling bad
because his father was gone of all these
mean things on the videos but then by
the time you page is the dungeon the
father says you know oh probably the
other that gives them the strength to
actually finish it and then they get
this pretty cool-looking storage and I
was legitimately awesome sword I don't
usually see like an entirely red sore
that's just that's very distinctive
demons blood yeah dalip that's awesome -
and then the demon tries to come back to
get the blood but then they just played
the little message that the dad said
before to get rid of the demon and they
say dad was awesome dude on pancake no
you're not a demon thanks hey if you're
gonna talk you be in the videos no she's
not remember she's gone now maybe this
is what the fifty-third level is I'm
sorry this is your 53rd level of hell
it's it deserves the name okay so you
know whatever the lesson to learn in it
I mean is it was unexpected like you
know the father to be saying that cast
up but I mean it's it's just sort of a
hey be smart don't change yourself and
be tough and you know you'll get through
fine ah the focus really is just the
dungeon and the creatures like half of
the like the past few episodes like the
actual creatures themselves like you
know that they've been okay like they've
been fastball on stuff but it's like
it's it almost feels like all the really
cool designs like that baits are a have
like in the first season stuff like that
seemed to come out in like two or three
episodes where you know they just put a
lot of effort into it and this seemed
like that episode like even the friggin
chairs like in that room with the
witches or whatever they are leavin the
chairs look great just every design
looks so cool and that was asking before
those hotdogs and the monster how can
those not be toys they make toys of all
these characters how can those not be
toys I'm asking you because I know you
pay certain toys and see okay because
this world is full of idiots and I could
see a bunch of dumb kids trying to eat
them and choking and dying I have no
faith in humanity kids doing this sorry
kids are choking on like swords and
stuff like that these toys are for
adults oh because that stops kids from
yeah well but they know the getting into
when they buy them at least danger toy
danger don't be an idiot and do not eat
this so we have warning labels on bleach
that says do not drink
we have warning labels on coffee that's
true bottles coffee that's it every time
I see that I always snicker like wow
just it just got to improve it don't
work people know you wonder
why they don't make action figures of
hotdogs and burgers say yours too yeah
those not the horrible movie that
everybody wants me to review it's like
all these food spokes characters come
together and apparently it's just got
off also maybe I'll review it like
everyone said make me requests to do it
so maybe I will I don't know but I just
agree with you by the way no way I do
not think it was about just the dungeon
I think it was definitely about you know
the way that Finn's dad was in a sense
trying to toughen up Finn well be he was
only a baby at that point he only saw
him as a baby I mean that's not no he
knew this was he knew this was gonna be
for later because remember uh in the
beginning where BMO is sitting there you
know all excited because you know Jake
is changing into things you see the
sparkles that they tried to beat up when
they find the first one and it says oh
you finally found this my Lifeson not
dead my of sparkles have sent you to
this finally so no he made it for the
future fit for when Finn got older and
he stood up for them why would he assume
he would be a winner because if you
notice when he holds up Finn and Finn
and Jake and just squeezes them you guys
are babies and he squeezes them Jake
starts giggling and laughing and Finn
starts crying and you see him squeeze
spin again and have this nasty look on
his face of spin is crying
oh but Finn is clearly not a wimp though
so why his dad's dead his death had been
dead for a while but that's why he's
making the Assumption as he's a baby
well yeah of course he's making the
Assumption well that when I was setting
it up for that later time when Finn is
older but he doesn't know he's gonna be
like when he's older that he should be a
better parent not make a dungeon just
let him off you should toughen him up
from that age five when I point though I
think it's more about that it's more
about the whole parents wanting more
from their kids instead of wanting their
kids to just be who they are you need to
be better than you are
don't be yourself
but even then he was doing his dancer
gets off scot-free there just like Dan
was cool yeah it's like they totally
forget about what a jerk it's what he
did almost no that won't argue that I
won't argue that at all but I mean then
again he doesn't prison a demon
partially into a sword I mean that's not
the best thing in the world I was this
one the when the demon drags him in are
we to assume that's how he died
Oh at this point in time uh yeah um from
my memory I don't think they say
anything else about how he dies I mean
we don't see robably what no that's not
true because the demon has changed there
and there's that video afterward yeah
that's right so we must um unless you
made it out of order but yeah that could
be possible too but but then it's inside
yeah that's true so you would have to
avoid yeah I don't know but no but I
would make sense so he could put the
video in there and then put the demon in
and then he's got but he had to put the
thing because remember no recording it
from outside yeah yeah because they
never as far as I remember they don't
say how their father dies again actually
going back to the whole thing of people
getting a little worked up over silly
things I remember when they initially
were talking about Finn and Jake being
brothers and you were having a little
trouble wrapping your head around it
people were really upset going how can
you not know what adoption is what's
wrong with you well I mean it's what
we're getting upset with that tune it's
like you're doing to upset yeah I'll say
it baby but you don't adopt a brother
for a dog for a dog yes that's I put
that together now in reality that excuse
me if my brain doesn't immediately jump
to oh what a dog a talking dog and a boy
are adopted they can be brothers it's
like it takes me a minute to get used to
the adventuretime world world oh no I'm
just I just it just made me remember
back to that episode in people getting
upset going tub what's wrong with you
how can you
No oh yeah people get really peed so but
I put together now but yeah I mean this
one it seemed mostly about you know the
journey of fighting these cool creatures
and stuff like that and it was cool um
they have this talent of making things
they're not dirty or gross look dirty
and gross like thanks Green Monster with
all the lungs I mean it's like it's
lumpy so so what but they give it these
little hairs and just the rights and
what he squeezes that thing in the
middle it's not even an area that would
be anything perverted but it just looks
like the most dirty thing in the world
when he does that well they also first
look at him you use like three spots
where just squirts out a liquid that's
quite impressive to do that to actually
make something disgusting that's really
you can't quite say why it's disgusting
would that be just be like dude you're
ugly as hell if you'd be like what's
going on
oh we're bros we tell us just tell you
the truth man and you are gross just
like it all thanks I get it with Finn
you could kind of buy anything no
totally serious like leaves it none I'll
be true with you bros and I'm helping
you out and then he's being helped out
it's just that's what kind of world in
Korean I just love bands kind of people
they create it I love it I love my god
so yeah it was it was definitely a fun
very creative episode I want to see
those hot dog hamburger toys screw the
children I'll die from them I'm all fun
with that yeah you're the dumb kids
no come bacon yeah don't make out with
your wife don't do go sex what you're
just gonna show your crotch oh my
crunches oh hello yeah it is same reason
I called you back here young man
yes it's because now you get to do the
fancy line I'm fine with that I don't
know it's not that hard
well they do it all you have to just sit
here and say Oh blah blah blah my
opinion of this is blah blah blah
there you have see I'll see you next
episode
Oh which is the appearance of one of my
favorite characters first appearance of
one of my favorite character